(high pitched sneeze)
- What was that?
- I don't know but it
sounded like a hamster dying.
- Or a goldfish's orgasm.
(high pitched sneeze)
- Anna, you feeling okay?
- I feel grea- (sneeze)
Great.
- Hey, Anna if you're sick,
you should go home and rest.
- I know. I'm not sick though.
- Anna there's no shame in being sick.
Technically I've never not been sick.
Doctors consider me legally dead.
- That's why you stay so trim.
- Yeah I'm dangerously frail.
- It's, um, just allergies.
(coughing)
- Anna if you're sick, the best place
for you to be is home, in bed.
- I can power through.
(Hacking)
- Oh God! Enough Anna. You're
gonna get all of us sick.
- No I had head lice last
February, no one even noticed.
- That was you?
- I had to burn most of my clothes.
- I can't take a sick day, okay?
I already scheduled all
my sick days this year.
- How do you know when
you're gonna be sick?
- Is it crystals?
I, you know, my wife's into
like the salty air and stuff.
- I don't know when I'm going to get sick.
I work when I'm actually sick so I can use
my sick days as extra vacation days.
I'm gonna be coming down
with the flu next month
so I can go wine tasting
and Trench foot in September
so I can see DJ Mouse Meat in Vegas.
- I love DJ Mouse Meat.
I'm a Mouse Meathead.
- I know it's wrong. I'm sorry.
- Anna. Everyone does that.
You really think I have walking polio?
- Yeah, remember when I had pneumonia?
I was kite surfing in Cabo with my wife.
I've actually never been
sick a day in my life.
I have the immune system of a cat.
- Did you know feline AIDS
affects 5 percent of all cats?
It's an epidemic.
Nobody's talking about it.
- What Elliot's trying
to say, is that it's okay
to take a sick day when
you're actually sick.
- You're right. You're right.
I'll go home. I can just log out.
- No Anna, it's okay. Get in bed.
We'll cover you. It's not a big deal.
- Really? Thanks guys.
- Five percent guys.
(cough)
That's one in every twenty cats.
Mr. Harris is at risk. He's
a very promiscuous cat.
- Hey Sarah it's me. Yeah
of course they bought it.
Alright. I will see you
in like twenty minutes.
You are going to love the
new bikini top I bought.
Okay. Alright. Bye!
A woo hoo.
(Car starts)
Anna you missed.
Get it in the basket at least!
Gross. Germs.
Come on!